ce n'est pas la première fois que
vladimir poutine est associé à des
affaires de meurtres ou de disparition
oui céline des disparitions mystérieuses
qui se multiplient depuis quelques
années maintenant parmi les journalistes
parmi les hommes d'affaires parmi les
opposants politiques
j'en ai sélectionné cinq pour vous quand
même des exemples assez emblématique de
ce qui se passe en russie par exemple la
journaliste hala politovskaïa en 2006
qui avait été assassiné froidement très
célèbre notamment évidemment parce
qu'elle travaillait notamment pour
mettre au jour des affaires de
violations des droits de l'homme elle
était assassinée en 2006 dans son
appartement on n'a jamais su qui était
le commanditaire
natalia estemirova en 2009 une militante
également des droits de l'homme qui
était enlevé qu'on a retrouvé quelques
heures plus tard assassiné dans un fossé
le domaine des affaires aussi n'est pas
épargnée dans ces disparitions
par exemple sergueï magnitski en 2009 un
avocat fiscaliste qui avait mis au jour
des machinations financière il était on
la laissait mourir à petit feu dans une
prison également aussi nous avons boris
nemtsov bien sûr nos opposants
politiques étaient assassinés il ya
quelques mois de cela
de là quelques pas en fait de l'ancien
palais d'été sarlat aussi quelqu'un qui
dénonçait très souvent tout ce qui se
passait au niveau politique
berezovski aussi voilà berezovski où un
homme d'affaires qui lui en fait il
était retrouvé mort dans sa salle de
bains dans les circonstances étranges au
royaume uni il ya beaucoup de gens qui
demanderaient d'ailleurs une enquête
publique comme c'était le cas pour le
cas d'en parler vraiment saint pierre
c'est important de rappeler quand même
qu' aucun lien qui dit vraiment monsieur
poutine mais selon certains il a créé
une sorte de climat de patriotisme de
paranoïa qui pousserait certains de ces
loyalistes à commettre des meurtres en
sort dont le président et ses partisans
font tous en fête pour faire taire les
opposants au régime
oui par exemple il ya beaucoup de
censure en russie faut savoir que le
gouvernement a beaucoup d'intérêt dans
tous les médias de masse donc il ya de
la censure également du harcèlement
judiciaire il suffit de penser par
exemple à alexeï navalni un opposant de
vladimir poutine ou encore le
milliardaire que lorsque au ski qui
avait passé de longues années derrière
les barreaux parce qu'il critiquait
beaucoup monsieur poutine est alors bien
sûr on peut pousser des gens à l'exil
comme garry kasparov donc être critique
de soutine
j'ai des échecs évidemment être
critiques de poutine en russie c'est pas
facile
non pas facile merci frédéric